[Music]
Love of mine. Someday you will die, but
I'll be close behind.
I'll follow you into the dark. No
blinding light. Or tunnels to gates of
white. Just our hands clasp so tight.
Waiting for the hint of a spark. If
heaven and hell decide that they both
are satisfied,
illuminate the nose on their vacancy
signs.
If there is no one beside you when your
soul embarks,
then I'll follow you into the dark.
In Catholic school, as vicious as Roman
rule, I got my knuckles bruised
by a lady in black. And I held my tongue
as she told me, "Son, fear is the heart
of love."
So I never went back.
If heaven and hell decide that they both
are satisfied,
illuminate the nose on their vacancy
signs.
If there's no one beside you when your
soul embarks,
then I'll follow you into the dark.
You and me have seen everything to see
from Bangkok to Calgary.
And the souls of your shoes
were all worn down. The time for sleep
is now, but it's nothing to cry about
cuz we'll hold each other soon in the
blackest of rooms.
If heaven and hell decide that they both
are satisfied,
illuminate the nose on their vacancy
signs.
If there's no one beside you when your
soul embarks,
then I'll follow you into the dark.
And I'll follow you into the dark.
So, this is Mufasa who just did that.
Let's wait for the damn police guard
pass.
>> It's the end of the world
>> as we know it. All right, take two. Hey
friends. So, um I just want to put a
huge thank you out there to Mufa Mother.
>> I'm I'm definitely going to use this for
bloopers in the outro. Take three.
>> Yes.
>> Take three. All right. So, hey friends.
So, I just want to put a huge thank you
out there to my good friend Mufasa for
doing the camera work on this wonderful
video that I've been working on for
months and months and months and months
and months. Mufasa, you're a gentleman
and a scholar. Where can people find you
online? You
>> can find me at YouTube and Instagram,
though. Instagram is your best bet
nowadays.
>> Mhm. And what is uh what is your handle?
>> Ah, Fuego Monster.
>> There we go. Cool. Thank you so much,
Mufasa. Of course. I love working with
you, buddy.
>> Anytime, DS.
>> Huzzah.
>> Take care.
>> Yes. Nailed it. Hey friends, I really
hope that you enjoyed this video. It has
been a long time in coming and uh there
was a lot of hard work and a lot of
really important input that went into
the creation of it and a lot of people
to thank for that too. Uh first and
foremost of course is Mufasa who you
already saw who handled all the camera
work here. Um, but also too, uh, this
project would absolutely not have come
to completion in the form that you just
saw were it not for the amazing guidance
of Jennifer Ever Swanson, who, uh, has
been steadily giving me notes and
performance suggestions for several
months now, and whose guidance and
support and just, you know, unbelievable
uh, ability to give me confidence in a
thing that I lacked confidence in has
been instrumental in getting it across
the finish line. So, thank you so much
ever for your support in making this
project happen. Um, I should probably
also give thanks to uh this the friends
of the channel. Uh, big thanks to Dark
Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys,
uh, Pyroer Light Toys, and Ultraoy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. Um, you can learn more
about all of these different companies
by checking out the links that I have
down in the description of this video.
And of course, uh, I need to thank my
wonderful supporters on Patreon, without
whom this video would not be possible.
In particular, I want to give a huge
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now. Thank you
all so much for your very, very generous
support. Uh, and as those of you who are
already FL patrons and Patreon
supporters know, you've been getting
sneak peeks at this for months now. Um,
so thank you all for watching and thank
you all for your feedback as well. And
if you out there watching uh enjoyed
what you saw and want to support me in
making more projects like this, the best
way to do that is to sign up to support
me on Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll leave a link to it down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
Um biggest reason to do that, you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring PO
spinning and flow arts to the whole wide
world. And you can get access to some
awesome rewards like getting your name
in the credits and the like. So please
go check that out. Uh, I will go ahead
and leave a link to some other PO
performances that I have done, fully
choreographed routines like this one,
uh, up on screen as well as down in the
description if you want to check out
some more examples of my choreographic
work. But regardless, thank you so much
for watching this. Um, thank you so much
for supporting this work and uh, I can't
wait to show you what the next one is.
It is already in progress and uh, it's
going to be a really, really awesome
one. Take care. Make sure you get
outside to flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon.
Peace.